Hi there.
Just before this video starts, I wanted to
briefly explain what it is.
About a week ago, we launched our first new
channel in two years: Extremities.
It’s about why and how the world’s most
remote settlements exist, told with stunning
visuals and exclusive interviews from these
places.
What you’re about to watch is the first
episode: it’s about Little Bay Islands--a
town that, for complex reasons, ceased to
exist after December 31st, 2019.
At the end of this I’m not going to ask
you to go sign up for CuriosityStream or to
check out HelloFresh or anything: I’m just
going to ask you, if you enjoyed this, to
go subscribe to the Extremities channel, and
check out the two other videos there, because
this is the only one that will ever go up
on Wendover Productions.
With that, please enjoy the video.
At 5 P.M. on December 31st, 2019, the MV Hazel
McIsaac pulled away from Little Bay Islands.
On board were the last few holdouts of those
who had called the tiny island hamlet home.
This would be the final time the town’s
regular ferry service pushed off from the
rustic collection of snow-dusted crimson,
off-white, and beige saltbox homes.
As it exited the protected harbor, the permanent
population of Little Bay Islands plummeted
from 54 to just two.
For those onboard, and the two still standing
on shore, the weight of the moment hung heavy
in the air.
Mike Parsons, who, along with his wife Georgina,
decided to stay, said of the final days that
a “palpable sadness” had enveloped the
islands.
Although an all-but-inevitable conclusion,
leaving hurt.
“Bartlett: This is nowhere.
There's nothing else there, you know.
But still, people got the love of the land
where they were born on.
I mean, you know this.”
As the ferry cut through the low-hanging fog
and faded away in the evening’s dying light,
and as the 2010s faded from present to past,
a tiny town on a couple tiny islands closed
a chapter of its story that had begun some
200 years prior.
What was once a boomtown-gone-bust was now
all but a ghost town.
That day, electricity that had powered the
H.L. Strong Academy, Aunt Edna’s B&B, the
two churches, and the dozens of heartily built
homes wrapping around the harbor, shut off.
Unopposed by streetlights and the hum of habitation—night
and its accompanying quiet settled over the
town of two, and Little Bay Islands became
the eighth remote community in Newfoundland
and Labrador this century to permanently relocate.
The abandonment of Little Bay Islands, and
the reason this small settlement existed in
the first place, is enmeshed in the intertwined
history, politics, and economics of the North
Atlantic—all of which, across centuries
of European settlement, have revolved around
a rather nondescript fish.
By the 2010s, Little Bay Islands—a name
left plural to acknowledge the community’s
straddling of both Little Bay and Mack Islands—was
on its last leg.
At its height, more than five hundred called
the small-but-bustling town nestled between
lush forest and rocky coast home.
What brought people to Little Bay Islands
and the coast of Newfoundland, had little
to do with what was on land, but rather what
swam in the surrounding waters.
“Thornhill Verma: But the reason why settlers
predominantly from Europe came to Newfoundland,
Labrador and populated the outports was because
of the proximity to this lush resource of
wild fish.
And that continues to be the case…”
Beginning with Paleo-Eskimo peoples arriving
around 1,000 BCE, then followed by the Little
Passage peoples two thousand years later,
indigenous hunter-gatherer societies were
the first to recognize the wealth of Newfoundland’s
teeming coasts.
Not long after the Little Passage peoples
had arrived, though, these waters became a
bit busier.
Northern and Western Europeans were next to
identify the region’s oceanic potential—and
unlike contemporary explorers, they weren’t
there for God… but for cod.
Simply put: “Bartlett: [00:10:43] Cod, when
in my time I grew up, and previous to that,
cod was King.”
Cod’s prominence, its centrality to life
in Little Bay Islands, and Newfoundland more
broadly, spans well beyond Wilfred’s lifetime;
going back not just generations, but centuries.
When Norse sailors landed on Newfoundland
hundreds of years prior to Columbus’s crossing,
they skirted from one cold, barren shore to
the next with little more than the prevalent,
easy-to-catch, high-in-protein fish to fill
their caloric needs.
For the Europeans that followed,
cod didn’t just represent a calorie-dense
source of sustenance, but a resource with
which they could turn a profit.
Although British and Basque fishing ventures
kept tight lips about their favorite spots,
it’s likely that enterprising vessels cut
across the Atlantic alongside and even before
Columbus and John Cabot in the 1490s.
Once Cabot had come across Newfoundland though,
the secret was out, as the explorer exclaimed
that these faraway waters were so well stocked
that all one had to do was stick a basket
in the ocean and it’d fill with fish.
While European explorers
carried with them a penchant to exaggerate,
Cabot’s description of fishing in the Northwest
Atlantic maps rather accurately onto the disposition
of the Atlantic Cod.
An omnivorous bottom-feeder, cod are both
perpetually lethargic and ceaselessly hungry,
and as such, gladly take bait and don’t
put up much of a fight once on a line.
Properly treated, cod keeps, too.
“Bartlett: And cod, one thing about cod
was all all salt, put on salt back then, so,
I mean, you could keep it for a long, long
time, year or two years or three years if
you had to.
I don't know how long you could if you really
need it.
But usually it was cut, split, and sold and
then taken back to England and Portugal and
Spain.”
Countries that, as Catholic, were eager to
find alternatives to warm-blooded meats during
lent.
As the fish gained popularity
across Europe—becoming a staple in markets
in the 1500s, and appearing in the pages of
Cervantes’ Don Quixote, Zola’s The Belly
of Paris, and Dumas’ Le Grand Dictionnaire
de Cuisine—European settlements took root
along the rocky shores of the continent’s
northeastern coast.
These hearty, self-reliant, coastal communities,
now known as “outports,” drove the growth
of Newfoundland from the 1700s onward.
Built on and around the water, Little Bay
Islands—only accessible by boat, angling
out at the rich waters of Notre Dame Bay and
the Grand Banks beyond but hugging the fragmented
and protective coast of Newfoundland—was
the quintessential outport.
The earliest census of Little Bay Islands
dates to 1825, but some locals like Wilfred
Bartlett believe that British fishers may
well have established year-round habitation
on the islands decades prior.
Whether settled in the 1820s or the 1720s,
Little Bay Islands embodies the era of fish-fueled
European expansion.
And without an abiding climate or much in
the way of arable land for agriculture like
its southern relatives off of Cape Cod, Little
Bay Islands, from its inception, would remain
a strictly ocean-oriented economy.
From the nineteenth century to the mid-twentieth,
Little Bay Islands enjoyed a period of blissful
stasis.
By 1950, the town, along with the rest of
Newfoundland, had become a part of Canada,
had added a few more saltbox homes, a couple
new processing plants, and was sheltering
more modern boats in its harbor.
But still, Little Bay Islanders went out each
day to work their corner of the cod industry.
At day's end, they picked their kids up from
the schoolhouse, and headed over to their
local union meetings.
When they had a chance, they caught up at
the Poacher’s Lounge for a drink.
When they made it to the weekend, they headed
to the crowded grocery stores and crammed
into the town’s two churches.
When winter turned to spring, they planted
root vegetables in home gardens, awaiting
the peak summer fishing season.
And when they tired after a long career, they
handed their work off to their children.
At mid-century, Little Bay Islands still happily
revolved around the same industry it always
had.
But, while change isn’t always continuous,
it is inevitable.
And soon, intruding engines of change showed
up right offshore.
It came in the shape of a 280-foot British
Fairtry trawling vessel appearing off the
coast of Newfoundland in 1951.
Alongside an invading fleet of smaller trawlers
from across Europe, the Soviet Union, and
Japan, this would change cod fishing forever.
While outsiders weren’t new, as fishers
from as far as Portugal seasonally visited
Little Bay Islands, the technology was.
“Bartlett: Then all of a sudden, the draggers
got involved where you could drop a net over
to start of a boat, or over the side for side
trollers, and go drag the bottom of whatever
is in front of that net certainly comes up,
there's nothing left.
And not only where we're taking a lot of cod,
but we're taking a lot of bycatch, too, because,
I mean, if you want a lot of cod and there's
other things in there you just throw it back
in the ocean dead.”
In just a decade, traditional methods used
by local fishers for generations—hook and
line, nets, cod traps—were superseded by
floating cities capable of hauling up tons
of fish and flash freezing them, all while
still at sea.
At the same time that massive ships consolidated
the fishing industry, politicians sought to
consolidate Canada’s coastal population.
In an effort to save on expensive government
provided services—ferries, power, healthcare—the
Centralization Program of 1954 and the Fisheries
Household Resettlement Program of 1965 moved
thousands from remote outports to population
centers.
In the 1950s and ‘60s, the waters around
Little Bay Islands had become overcrowded
and towns not so different from it began feeling
pressure to relocate.
But not only did Little Bay Islands persist
during this period; it thrived—its docks,
shops, processing plants, churches, and school
hummed with activity.
For the moment, there were enough fish to
support both the cities at sea pulling it
in by the ton and the town’s continued small-scale
operations.
That moment, however, proved fleeting.
With innovation, mechanization, and the ruthless
pursuit of efficiency came disaster.
By the 1970s, annual fish
hauls were tripling the tonnage of those from
three decades prior.
Cod populations couldn’t keep up.
With collapse on the horizon, Canadian officials
took action—turning back foreign vessels
and placing quotas on the fish.
But it was far too little, far too late.
By 1990, in some spots, one could hardly find
the fish at all.
“Bartlett: I faced up Labrador coast five
hundred miles north from where I lived, and
they had a moratorium up there for two years,
couldn't get a cod to eat.
But, you know, it is, like I said, nobody
listened.”
In 1992, the Canadian government banned nearly
all cod fishing.
The moratorium aimed to revive the stock over
the course of a few years.
Today, nearly 30 years later, the moratorium
is still in place.
The collapse of the cod industry
put Little Bay Islands in an impossible position.
The town was, the town is, in many ways, a
picture-perfect fishing community.
“Bartlett: Little Bay Islands is one of
the most beautiful communities around.
It's, it's a beautiful harbor there, in fact,
there's two inlets there, you can get a small
boat in one end, and a big boat through the
other… it’s an island off of a harbor--that's
what it is.
And it's... no matter how bad the weather
gets, it’s still sheltered.
And I guess that's one of the reasons why
it's not a very big island.
People had to go off the island and get enough
wood to keep themselves going for ship building,
that kind of thing… because according to
an outsider it was it was a small island.
But it was located to the fishing grounds
so that was the main thing.”
Now, though, the most important fish was gone.
As an industry, fishing didn’t line the
pockets of Little Bay Islanders, it didn’t
create massive financial wealth, but it did
support a unique way of life.
It nurtured the small-town comradery that
only blooms after decades of waiting together
in the same lines, singing the same hymns,
and drinking the same draft beers.
It furthered family bonds as mothers and fathers
taught their trades to daughters and sons.
As the rest of the world moved toward urban
centers, Little Bay Islands offered an alternative
path for those enchanted by a rural, rugged
lifestyle deeply entangled with the surrounding
landscape.
Fishing made it all possible, and Little Bay
Islands had stayed loyal.
The town had no backup plan, no alternative
industry to pick up the slack should something
go awry.
Here, cod was king.
And now, cod was dead.
While fishing stayed a consistent economic
driver for centuries, the actual, day-to-day
practice has proved dynamic; requiring flexibility,
and at times, mobility.
“Thornhill Verma: [00:31:15] So resettlement
is as much a part of outport life in the province
of Newfoundland and Labrador as the fishing
that brought people there in the first place.”
Some—the earliest seasonal fishing parties,
and later, families relocating in search of
better home bases—moved by choice.
Others—indigenous peoples and outport communities
deemed too far from urban hubs—were pushed
or forced to relocate.
While Little Bay Islands had dodged resettlement
by choice or force for well over a century,
by the late ‘90s it was becoming difficult
to ignore the creeping thought that their
time to pull up stakes was quickly arriving.
In the years following the
moratorium, Little Bay Islanders turned their
efforts to crab, shrimp, and capelin—fish
that have kept Newfoundland’s economy afloat
through to today.
“Thornhill Verma: So while the East Coast
cod fishery collapse, what's popularly known
as the cod moratorium happened in July of
1992 and it's still underway today, I think
what people don't realize is that this is
still a billion-dollar industry--fisheries.”
Gone, though, were the jobs that cod provided
on shore and at sea.
Post-collapse, the newly jobless left in droves.
“Jenn: [00:30:01] And in the decade that
followed, you had 10 percent of the population
of Newfoundland and Labrador, move away.”
As Little Bay Islands’ fishers moved to
the mainland to find work, institutions that
relied on their presence—the grocery stores,
churches, and school—began to falter.
In 2009, the crab processing plant, the town's
last major employer, shuttered, leaving the
women who worked the plant little choice but
to relocate or rely on unemployment programs.
In just a few decades, the bustling town—with
boats whizzing past its wharves by day and
the Poacher’s Lounge filling to standing
room only by night—had taken on a melancholy
quiet.
As families peeled out of town one by one,
the murmurs of wholescale resettlement gained
momentum.
In Newfoundland and Labrador,
the term resettlement is a loaded one.
“Bartlett: [00:25:13] I don't know, resettlement
is a bad word for me, I mean, we did that
back in Joey Smallwood’s day and it is a
terrible thing to do, uprooted people that,
you know, that was there all their lives,
and it didn't improve their bit one bit in
the world.”
In the wake of the cod collapse, the government
revived the unpopular mid-century policy in
2010.
This time around, the resettlement program
offered a proportionally larger payout, prohibited
the provincial government from initiating
the process, and, if viable, required the
community to approve the decision by a 90%
vote.
Still, more amenable terms aside, such a move
was bound to hurt:
“Thornhill Verma: But I think the reason
why it really strikes an emotional chord in
Newfoundland and Labrador, is because it feels
like the death of this way of life.
And so I felt that even when we sold my grandfather's
home in Little Bay East on the southern shores
of Newfoundland and Labrador, here I had this
physical link to a community that my ancestry
was tied up in for hundreds of years, and
then for that to be gone and to not be able
to have that physical link to a place that
I remember growing up and going with my father
to his childhood home and beachcombing along
the beach and being able to go out on the
dory with my family members, you know, to
have that access pulled is more than ‘let's
do something different next year, summer vacation.’
It's this connection to place and culture
and heritage and tradition.
And so I think that's difficult for people.”
Opportunity created Little
Bays Islands.
When opportunity died, the town was bound
to soon follow.
As the Grand Banks clogged with oversized
trawlers, and fishing transformed from a timeless
profession to one with an expiration date,
outport youth began to look west for opportunity.
“Bartlett: And that's what has happened
is no jobs, one time, when the fishery was
going to go, in the summertime when you're
out of school, well, you got a job at a fish
plant, working in the fish plant, or you went
in the boat with your father or went down
to the wharf, cutting out tongues, you made
a living.
But now there’s nothing for them to do.
Come out of school there is no… very few
places to pick up a job in Newfoundland and
Labrador today.”
In many cases, their own families urged them
to move on.
“Thornhill Verma: I mean, my grandfather
was the last fisherman in our family, and
that wasn't by accident.
That was by design.
My grandfather and my grandmother wanted to
make sure that their four boys had an education,
and certainly Newfoundlanders and Labradorians
are all educated, whether that's on the land
and sea or in a classroom, but they very much
wanted their four boys to receive a classroom
education and to go on and have careers that
allowed them to leave the ports.”
As the hope that the fishery would soon recover
faded, Little Bay Islands families and youth
made their way to the mainland—leaving behind
an aging population deeply tied to the landscape,
but unmoored from economic opportunities and
far from medical services.
With the processing plants
shuttered, the school empty, the local bar
dry, the fire department closed, and the town
doctor long gone, Little Bay Islands in 2015
was a shell of its former self.
For the 95 aging full-timers, 45-minutes away
from medical facilities and grocery stores,
assuming fair weather, the time had arrived
to put resettlement up for a vote.
The result: 85 votes for, 10 against—missing
the required 90% benchmark by 0.53%.
Four years and zero miracles later, they voted
again.
This time, it was unanimous: Little Bay Islands
would resettle.
In the months following the
vote, Little Bay Islanders soberly planned
their next move, packed their belongings,
and, in some cases, converted their homes
to operate off-grid, anticipating summer visits.
In addition to the $250,000 Canadian dollars
Little Bay Islanders were to receive for relocating,
they retained their property.
Gone though, were the costly government-supplied
amenities.
No more power, no more snow plowing, and no
more ferry service.
Those with unwavering bonds to the place where
they grew up, where they raised families,
where they felt at home, would be back…
but it wouldn’t be the same.
It couldn’t be.
As the MV Hazel McIsaac disappeared
into the December night, and the Parsons ducked
back into their newly off-grid home to ring
in the New Year, Little Bay Islands entered
an era both foreign and familiar.
Over were the centuries of permanent settlement
and decades of direct connection to mainland
Canada.
Returning, though, was the remoteness and
self-sufficiency that defined the outport’s
earliest days—a uniquely disconnected way
of life that drew many to the islands in the
first place.
In recent years, seasonal visitors, sea kayakers,
photographers, authors, and artists have descended
upon the striking landscapes and quaint coastal
communities of the likes of Little Bay Islands.
But fishermen, like Wilfred Bartlett, and
grandchildren of fishermen, like Jenn Thornhill
Verma aren’t yet ready to agree to the Devil’s
bargain that tourism presents.
“Thornhill Verma: My family still lives
there.
As much as I'm proud that people go there
to visit, I want people to go and stay for
a long time, not just a good time.”
Staying for a long time, though, requires
a healthy fishery.
A healthy fishery requires something that
Newfoundland outport communities can’t procure
on their own—future forward, stringent,
protective fishing policy, at the national
and international level.
Outports today, while built
on a foundation of enterprising and independent
spirit, bend to global forces.
But then again, Little Bay Islands, and outports
like it, have always been at the mercy of
economics and politics well beyond their wharves—spanning
the Northern Atlantic and beyond.
It’s likely too late for Little Bay Islands,
but this doesn’t have to be the end for
outports.
The lesson of Little Bay Islands is not that
these places’ rural, small-town lifestyle
can’t exist.
Instead, it’s that it can’t exist in a
vacuum.
While proudly independent and situated well
on the periphery, the survival of these extremities
hinges on their relationships and ties to
the center.
And while the people of outports get to decide
when they resettle, it’s much larger forces
that will decide if they have to.
I really hope you enjoyed this video.
As a reminder, this was the pilot episode
of our new channel, Extremities, and this
is the first and last ever episode of Extremities
that will go up on Wendover.
So, if you enjoyed this, please go subscribe
to Extremities at the link in the description
to get all of our future videos.